welcome to this video playing I slim
montia something like that okay he's
played some we had been known him hybrid
whatever a six I don't know this is some
Malaysia yeah okay now is going for this
for this snake vanoni maneuver with the
g6 yeah nothing nothing great at the end
for for black and white as a very
comfortable position here
with a very substantial advantage in
space
okay yeah it's it's both good young now
can take with the Queen keep a tidy
structure okay let's see how do I
continue here night too before could be
an idea
maybe
now you should take on c4 now I guess
exchange something get the B file open
okay night to you for now I guess there
also is 93 h5 as a possible way forward
maybe go for this regrouping night h5 is
quite nice if it appears them it would
provoke some some more weaknesses like
f6 or something like that night age five
what I can take and Ruby seven eyes in
this good in addition there is still
night age 59 th five friends rookie aid
okay let's let's do this rookie aid now
with the check and mate on g7 not even
sure what he plays now what does this
reply him
I'm not quite sure what is playing maybe
95
um can I not simply take yet again I
mean besides bishop age six and other
moves Bishop h6 is quite good come on
that's enough takes I take g6 and then
made coming okay yeah this is he can do
at least for the moment I can take them
again and then F 1 F for at the end now
we're not overlooking something else
would be really frustrating after the
cause of the game but then I didn't want
to spend any more time and risk to lose
on time at the end this is the usual
scenario in those games you can
basically only lose on time okay so this
is this is nice yeah but how to win now
maybe in getting Quinn to g3 is a good
threat
yeah still and here maybe look f1 or
taking a drug everyone maybe even easy i
am rook everyone take care now check and
rook g6 em come on this should decide
matters right black resigns yeah that
was good to get in be very frustrating
to lose this after this very one sided
this one very one-sided cause of the
game yeah white is just overwhelming him
or all pieces are better than blacks
pieces and two bishops everything and
ninety-six was especially accommodating
getting me to ieave her to age five with
this thread rupee aid with a check even
yantian their bishop g6 was even clearer
him yeah this was even clearer I
understand gem now he has no way to
block with 95 even but ok this was was
winning as well and always + + 7
something along along these lines check
yeah ok I'm satisfied there there wasn't
anything that he could do right thanks
for watching